[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview the first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
Guardians Deputy political editor
Jessica elgot and the pr consultant Alex
Dean they'll be with us from now right
up until just before midnight so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now well the garden here is that
uh Rishi sunak May face a rebellion from
within his own party over a possible
post-brexit Northern Ireland trade deal
and that one of the detractors could be
his predecessor Boris Johnson
the telegraph offers a note of
skepticism from the Democratic unionist
party as to whether a deal should
actually be struck
the times describes reaching any deal as
the biggest test yet for Rishi sunak
the express criticizes the BBC director
General Tim Davey for saying it's
amazing that people are happy to pay the
annual license fee of 159 pounds
the eye carries a poll suggesting that 7
out of 10 people surveyed believe water
Executives should be held criminally
responsible for the pollution in the
UK's Rivers
the mail reports that the health
secretary Steve Barkley has ordered an
investigation into new NHS guidelines on
dealing with patients gender identity
the financial times reports that the
price of European natural gas has
reached its lowest level for 18 months
the mirror has an exclusive interview
with former Royal Butler Paul Burrell
who says he wants to share the late
Princess Diana's secrets with her sons
before he dies
the son has the story of former love
Island contestant Kaz Crossley who's
been released from jail in the United
Arab Emirates without charge
and the star is worried about the
dangers of artificial intelligence and
so-called chat Bots
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Jessica
elgot and Alex Dean welcome to both of
you let's start with the guardian at the
front page there and uh they're
reporting on a possible Tory Rebellion
over any uh future Northern Ireland deal
where she sunette
last minute negotiations a very um it
wasn't broadcast that he was heading out
for these negotiations but uh those have
gone ahead Jessica
yeah so this is obviously a moment this
is one of the most you know difficult
moments for Rishi sunak uh in his in his
Premiership so far he's going to have to
um Square it off not only with rebels in
his own party but with the dup because
that's so important for the restoring
government at Stormont
um so he's it is is obvious now that he
wanted to he would like to spend the the
time in Belfast talking to those parties
including Sinn Fein who were the largest
party there and there are obviously
signs I think and everyone's reporting
tonight the dep is pretty skeptical and
is said that any deal needs to meet
seven tests for it to to go back into
restoring that executive at Stormont but
um you know there is some ground that
the eu's probably conceded which is on
on some customs checks there's a new
system that's been devised by the UK
that they can use which is a bit of a
win for Rishi neck but the big problem
is the role of the European Court
Justice in policing at the Northern
Ireland protocol and that that remains
although there are now some new stages
before you would get to the ecj
um but the the sort of principle of the
ecj itself is the thing that the dup uh
and brexite is in in the Tory party are
particularly uh exercised about
the guardian reporting that uh some in
the party are fearing an intervention
from Boris Johnson in all of this Alex
well the situation for any British prime
minister is that you always kind of
wonder what to do with and about your
predecessors and this prime minister has
rather more of those around than most so
there's always going to be that question
and I you know I definitely sense in the
Tory party a good amount of skepticism
about uh doing a deal certainly without
the green light from the dup uh the ERG
have said they will move in lockstep
with the dep and I think some of them at
least will um really mean that but I
think on the other hand people in notori
party see Boris Johnson around a
recorder at the moment and they suspect
that he's going to take a role in in
lots of things he's actually kept his
powder pretty dry I think the bigger one
on this it is the biggest test for the
prime minister so far if he can achieve
progress on it it'll be a real coup now
if there's a deal to be done it looks
like the labor party will vote with the
government so it's not actually a
prospect of it failing um in the House
of Commons but the Optics really matter
and lots of the Skeptics about Richie
sunaki and the conservative party on the
right will hate hate hate the idea of
legislation going through with labor
support but without theirs so even if
you can get it through on paper he's
going to have to do some wooing of his
own back benches yeah the telegraph
reporting that the dep not totally happy
and that the Prime Minister admitting
that there's still
work to do in order to to win the up
approval so it's not not over the line
by any means Jessica
no it I mean it's certainly
um I mean in a way it can it sort of can
get over the line anyway there's there's
a question mark I think over whether we
should soon like actually even needs to
hold a vote to make these changes to the
protocol he may not actually need to
although
um he probably he might want to he might
choose to because
um he would like to sort of demonstrate
that he's prepared to put it to
Parliament and beat it and for it to be
debated there and and like Alex says it
would probably be carried on the back of
Labor boats but um but but so nice you
know got a bit of a mandate problem in
that he was elected only by MPS not by
his party and not by the country so you
know if he does something major like
this and carries it on the back of just
uh and carries it on the back of Labor
votes and doesn't have a majority in his
party
um then you know that's that sort of
says quite a bit about his own authority
although you know I think it the ERG
um is not is not the um the force it
once was in the Tory party that kind of
um I mean there's obviously a lot of
committed rights it is still in the Tory
party but some of the big names from
that time including Steve Baker is now a
Northern Ireland Minister he seems to be
in his post he seems to be content with
with this deal so far as that's what
that's what that's what we're hearing so
um you know there's they don't have
quite the organized operation that they
had before so I think it would probably
be quite a touch and go
okay we're going to break uh away from
that for a second because we have some
breaking news from our Sports
correspondent Rob Harris
um who was just on the news at 10
speaking to us about this uh story and
this is the bids in for Manchester
United also Jim ratcliffe's ineos has
also lodged a bid for Manchester United
um we understand
Boyhood United fan
um he announced interest first in
January in bidding and we're told it's
it's been submitted it comes as the soft
deadline has just passed that was for 10
p.m this evening and earlier we were
reporting that Sheikh Yasin bin Hamad
al-tani the chairman of Qatar Islamic
Bank he submitted the first formal bid
for the Premier League club as far as we
were told so just to reiterate that
piece of breaking news so Jim rack lives
ineos has also lodged a bit for
Manchester United we understand we'll of
course keep you updated on that story
um should any more information come into
us so let's return to our press preview
um so Alex it was your turn to
talk about
the uh
story in their Daily Telegraph to brexit
and the negotiations and we were
previously saying Jessica was alluding
to the fact that this is really a
massive test for Rishi sunaka the
probably biggest test of his Premiership
yeah I agree with that I also think it's
a test of the Parliamentary conservative
party because we've had three prime
ministers in a row now uh Torn To Be A
Boris job Theresa May Boris Johnson Liz
truss who have all been taken down by
their own side if you're a conservative
party prime minister uh the biggest
threat to you with all due respect to
Lane Farsi is not the opposition it's
those who sit behind you and it will be
a big decision if uh our members of the
conservative party don't want to back
the Prime Minister over something like
this well he will widely be seen as
making real progress on an issue of
substance and import I know that there
are issues and details that people will
really care about I think Jessica is
absolutely right to point to the fact
that the ERG has been somewhat de-fanged
it's not of course not just Steve Baker
Chris Eaton Harris another of their
luminaries is an office too and they're
both seemingly content with the
legislation that's being proposed I did
see Jeffrey Donaldson of the dep saying
today that real progress has been made
and he didn't seem as pessimistic as the
negotiations there can sometimes prove
to be so I actually think this would be
tremendous for the Prime Minister if he
can get it over the line but what we all
agree on I think is it's high stakes
Jessica what do you think this tells us
about the prime minister's level of
confidence because there are the the
various eurosceptic Tory MPS as Alex was
saying it's perhaps those on your side
the the ones that you have to fear the
most
um he must feel that he has a very good
chance of securing this deal
yeah and I think that that's almost
certainly about you know having you know
the backing of some of these quite
senior brexities
um you know in his in his cabinet and in
his on his front bench and so you know
that's not to say that someone like
Boris Johnson couldn't take this as a
moment to kind of make a big
intervention against sunac
um and that's a risk that you know the
Prime Minister will know about uh and be
anticipating and and and you know
obviously have to devise a strategy to
deal with
um but I think you know that that can
you know there's plenty of people who
are not big fans of Boris Johnson in the
in the uh conservative parliamentary
party either so you know that that
that's an intervention that could go
either way for him I think British sunak
has throughout the whole the course of
his
um you know Premiership since since
October
um sort of tried to present himself
particularly on the world stage as
someone who can you know different to
particularly trust and Boris Johnson a
sort of reasonable negotiator he's he's
very much tried to to present himself
that over you know trying getting a deal
on with with France and with President
macron on small boats you know very you
know really trying to uh heal that
relationship with Paris so again I think
that this will help sort of embellish
that relationship if we can get this
deal over the line but the big question
mark over it is is the dep and the
restoration of that executive at
Stormwind and you know if the dep still
refused to go in and and at the moment
it seems very very difficult to find
something that would persuade them to to
do that then you know this the problems
continue in Belfast let's move on to the
the story of Nicola bully um entering
the fourth week of her being missing an
intervention from the former victims
commissioner Dame Avira bairdon and she
said the force the Lancashire police
force would not have revealed similar
details if the missing person had been a
man this the criticism that um much of
the detail put into the public domain
was simply unnecessary Alex
yeah I don't know if that's right yet
because I don't know enough about the
investigation and I with a bit of
hesitation I I don't not sure Dane Vera
does either
um it's been a while of course since I
prosecuted or defended but I've seen the
police operating in a number of
situations it's very easy to be
skeptical or cynical about what the
police do but there are generally
reasons for them uh doing something like
this and I saw the BBC earlier carrying
some suggestion that uh very sadly and
and badly the family of this uh Missing
woman may have been the subject of
approaches from others up to and
including blackmail whereby this
information was going to come into the
public domain one thing that people do
agree on is that it came into the public
domain from the police with the family's
knowledge they knew it wasn't a surprise
so it may be that there are things that
police aren't disclosing because they
can't in the course of this
investigation which Merit or warrants uh
what they have done and indeed if that's
right fight somebody in the end maybe
prosecuted for that behavior so I I
understand why emotions run so high over
a case like this it's it's gripped so
many people desperate to want to see
this woman back in her home but I'm not
sure I'd go immediately to cry of sexism
uh over it yeah they may have mishandled
it I hope not but there may be reasons
they can't yet disclose about it and we
should bear that in mind but Jessica we
do know that uh Lancashire police have
started at their own internal review
into how they have handled the
investigation
yeah and obviously we also saw um the
Home Secretary as well Brotherman say
that she had some concerns over it
um you know get trying to get answers
from Lancaster Police about the
background of why they disclosed it and
I think you know I think that there is
there I found the disclosure quite
troubling although you know I suspect
that
um and and there was very little in the
police press conference which
um suggested that there was a really
there was a really significant reason
for disclosing this information as part
of the uh you know help to help people
search for Nicola bullet to Aid
um any you know the rest of the
investigation and obviously the fact
that was mentioned is the pressure that
there's been on the family
um but you know I think there's it's
very it's quite difficult to see this a
similar situation being declosed
disclosed about a man particularly never
a man was experiencing a you know an
embarrassing uh kind of dysfunction
perhaps and they'd turn to alcohol
because of that it it would be certainly
eyebrow raising to hear
um the police to disclose that as a part
of the investigation and I think you
know I think the sensitivities around it
I can see why it's made people Flinch
and especially senior politicians okay
Jessica and Alex thank you very much for
the moment we are going to take a break
uh coming up fast moving developments in
the possible sale of Manchester United
so fast in fact that the papers can't
quite keep up we'll discuss that deal
and the latest breaking news next stay
with us
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me Jessica albott and
Alex Dean yes there they are a bit tardy
but they're there let's have a look at
this story regarding uh the bid sport
Manchester United so the the front of
the mirror they've got um altani
confirming a four billion
bid Qatari bid but we just broke the
news while we um was going through the
papers a little while ago that so Jim
ratcliffe's ineos has also lodged a bid
for Manchester United
um the deadline was 10 o'clock and
before
just before the deadline we were only
aware of the one bid so it's um getting
a little bit more interesting Alex
that's right and as with any commodity
more than one bidder is very good if
you're selling something and makes it
quite likely that your price will be
something you can control rather more
than if there was only one uh bidder
that said one of the things we do know
about the Qatari bit is that they'd
undertaken to take on the very sizable
debt that the club is under and write it
off and we don't yet know whether uh Jim
Radcliffe is going to make a um similar
commitment I imagine if he's going to be
competitive he's now going to have to
um so it's going to be very good news I
think for the club either way and for
people who are skeptical about this um
kind of investment from abroad I just
look at the success that Lester's had
with King power and the and the influx
of capital that's come to the club since
um since that's happened at one end and
then of course wrexham at the other with
their very famous Hollywood
um ownership it really can be great for
a club to get this kind of investment
it's doubly good to have two bidders and
we want whether they will be the only
two because it was a softer deadline at
10 o'clock Jessica
yeah absolutely and of course they could
be um they could be further further
um bits for it I think that one of the
things that both obviously both parties
are trying to sort of present themselves
well to to the fans both saying that
their lifelong fans of the club both
promising to to make it debt-free and
and to restore its former glories which
is which you know seem along will seem a
long way away for many
um United fans
um I mean I mean I think there obviously
will be uh inevitable
um concerns about the prospects of a
Qatari investment in the Premier League
club but you know we've got we've got
you know a club owned effectively by
Saudi Arabia
um one by you know senior at the former
Thai
um uh leader so I think um you know it's
obviously not unprecedented and and you
know we have they also have the
ownership of Paris saint-german by Qatar
as well so
um but again it always raises questions
when you know it's kind of an
effectively State bidder for a club yes
we shall see how it all ends to the
times Alex and retail sales apparently
are better than expected some positive
news
yeah it's really good news and the
government will breathe a little sigh of
relief seeing uh news like this people
watch The High Street and fluctuations
on GDP very closely they've had some
close calls haven't they so we that just
didn't dip into recession in the last
month and we saw three consecutive
months in a row of a visibly small
declines in inflation taking those
things together with something like this
the government's going to feel uh in a
pretty good place economically certainly
better than we were in the Autumn last
year so it's by no means out of the
woods but this is really good positivity
for the UK economy
about 20 seconds Jessica
yeah I mean obviously one of the things
that's boosting sales in January is that
because people are are taking advantage
of sales and because you know people are
probably trying to buy things that they
couldn't afford to buy before and that's
good news for retailers but they've had
to slash their prices
um considerably and after and compared
to January last year um sales values are
down as you'd expect them to be with
inflation this high and inflation's
still still in double digits is still a
big concern or a big bit of something
that really informs Jeremy Hunt's budget
in a three few weeks time